بجانب هاري وميجين كان هناك بعض الاسماء
الجدليه التي طفت على السطح قبل نحو شهرين
من حفل التتويج الامير اندرو شقيق الملك
والمجرد من القابه الملكيه يرفض الخروج من
قصره في ويندسور لانه لن يكون قادرا على
تحمل تكاليف السياقه عند قطع المنحه
السنويه في ابريل المقبل ويلوحه بكتابه
مذكرات على خطب شقيقه بحسب بعض التقارير
البريطانيه تقارير اخرى تبرز رفضا
المحتملا لحضور الحفل من قبل بعض النجوم
هل تنجون مثلا الذي كان مقربا من ديانا
وحتى ادى في مراسم جنازتها في عام
1997 سيكون من الغريب ان يغني امام زوجها
السابق وعقيلته كامله طبعا
احد اهم الفنانين في بريطانيا ملتزم
بجولته الغنائيه في امريكا الشماليه ويوم
التتويج من المقرر ان يكون في تكساس اخيرا
النجمه العالميه اديل من المحتوى الام
ترفض الحضور ايضا في حفلها الاخير فلاش
قالت انها تعاني من الام الظهر المزمنه
ولا تملك اي ارتباطات فنيه في جدولها بعد
الخامس والعشرين من مارس
[موسيقى]